I had twenty thousand dollars left in my  credit cards and I I don't have a job I  don't have a way to pay my bills I was  paying my bills every month with credit  cards and it looked like everything was  good but I only had four or five more  months like that when the fifth month  came everything was done my car got  repoed but I was driving parking it all  over the place this is two thousand okay  I'm parking my car in Granada Hills a  mile away behind the park to walk to my  house so you know so you don't get  reposed doesn't come in yeah eventually  90 days later I turned my car in I'm  paying my phone bill in the following  way I'm calling Nextel no joke and I'm  asking Nextel what will 73 dollars get  me how many days I owed fifteen hundred  dollars to Nextel I haven't paid my  phone bill they would say 73 dollars  will turn your phone on for six days can  you do it for ten days they would say  yes I would negotiate paying phone  payment by days